to have zach frankie on the mound to
finish off this two-game series on the
season he has 14 starts that record is
beautiful at six and two a three-two
count to isaiah connor falefa
and there's a line drive to right field
chaz mccormick back out there for the
second straight knight puts it away
for the first out of this game
great pitch
dotsome up on the outside corner nate
lowe disagrees with vic carapaza
that one towards the middle underneath
the glove of cranky but positioned
perfectly jose altuve zack ricky has a
strong one two three perk that's jordan
lyles 30 year old right hander jose
altuve stands in for the astros
and altuve drives one deep to left field
carrying well good
wraps up last night's game with a slam
and starts tonight's game off with a
home run to left center
team leading 14th home run of the year
kick start in this astros offense with a
big swing
[Applause]
and this one on the ground third base
that could be two culvers in the second
one on to first in time double play and
bregman
that was kind of a weird gate as he
crossed first base
i'm not sure that he's entirely right
yeah he's got a little limp going you
can see as he put his head down to
really try and drive through that bag to
try and beat it out
that's when it came up and bit him
that one softly lined out near second
base and kinder philippa is there to
reel it in
all right the ending is over but altuve
with a lead off home run
2-2 from lyles
and he got him swinging
like you say he strikes out a lot
one away
oh look ouch breaking ball hits correa
in the back yeah that was an 87 mile an
hour change up that just never got back
down in the zone just traced right into
the back of carlos
chaz mccormick stands in
get going chaz mccormick already has a
home run this year against lyles give
him two
jazz median devil a two-run home run
it's three-nothing astros
after you have to have a guy get hit by
a pitch the next guy goes deep to back
him up well done chaz we're seeing chaz
mccormick's power i'll bring up martine
maldonado
maldonado sends one to pretty deep left
field all the way back looking up good
astros with three home run
and lead this game four to nothing
baldi's first career hit
against jordan lyles a home run on an o2
pitch eli white leading things off 3-2
white shoots this one out to right field
it's carrying pretty well it is gone
eli white goes the other way and the
rangers are on the board it's home run
derby tonight that's eli white's first
major league home run
when he misses high that's paul forbes
swinging a miss zach cranky has two
strikeouts tonight both times nate lowe
has been the victim he gets through the
third allows one run it's a 4-1 astros
lead
3-2 pitch and a breaking ball strike
three call garcia down looking and that
is out number one
this one on the ground shortstop connor
falefa across the diamond in time takes
care of guriel and it's a one two three
for jordan
swing and a miss got him up with the
fastball zach grenkey picks up his third
strikeout back-to-back hitters he has
struck out one way here in the port
that's hit hard but caught by yuli
guriel
line drive out
gallo retired for the second out
ground ball playable
third baseman robel garcia throws out
nick solak zach grinky has a one two
three four three of his four innings
have been perfect
2-2
and he got him swinging sean lyles
second time around
punches him out one away
miles straw flied out to right his first
time tonight following suit with three
home runs all from right hand hitter
straw bidding for a fourth and he
hit it
miles straw
his first home run
since his fifth major league at bat when
he hit one out in baltimore straw into
the crawford boxes
and the astros lead this game 5-1
i can't wait to see the dugout reaction
to this one they have got to be loving
this they may just
play it cool oh they're going to stone
them aren't they
straws last home run came in 2018.
maldonado hits one high and deep to left
center field all the way back is garcia
he can't make the play
martin maldonado jogging into second
base with a two out double maldi with a
home run followed by a double tonight
[Applause]
bouncer shortstop
and kind of fulfill throws out altuve
that will end the inning but miles straw
with a homer
there's a base hit
down that first base line takes a little
carom off the wall toward mccormick
and willie is aboard here in the fifth
inning
says yuli will make the play to second
for one correa will turn the double play
with zach cranky covering 3-6-1
wraps up the fifth inning
and a four-pitch walk to start the fifth
inning
sharply hit past the diving nick solac
into right field jordan alvarez joins
the hit club tonight
he's now one for three with a single in
the right putting runners on first and
second so lyles is done just shy of 80
pitches taylor hearn was warming out
there he'll be coming on payoff
and this one on the ground third base
culberson with a great stop hops up
throws out correa and the inning is done
so hearn gets through the fifth
unscathed
then he hits this one up the middle
that's a base hit
third rangers hit of the ball game
and so isaiah is on and
no doubt the start to another streak he
had the 11 gamer end last night and
3-0
and that's ball four and greg not gonna
like that one very much
because it was
right near the corner and his body
language communicated everything
he needed to say
2-2 and that one on the ground and that
is through base hit kind of felefa got a
pretty good start but he will hold at
third you do have to be careful in this
ballpark we talked about it a little bit
yesterday
and so the rangers played a little safe
with one out but they have the bases
loaded here joey gallo bats
tall third strike top of the zone
right on the corner zach grinky a big
second out
and he was dancing around it there with
joey gallo but picked up a big strikeout
and on his way out with a 5-1 lead
they'll get a nice hand from the mid-may
park crowd looks really has come on to
pitch here for houston and it's three
balls and a strike to solace here it
comes
and this one on the ground and through
into left field that's a base hit
that'll get two runs to the plate so
solac delivers with a two out single and
he makes it a 5-3 ball game
jazz drives one deep to left field he
has done it again
jazzy fizz a two-home run game astros
lead six to three
what'd you say about him looking
comfortable in the big leagues
wow
438 feet
what
that was a bomb
eli white already with a home run
tonight leading things off
this ball hit well deep out to right and
that one is gone
well how about that eli white gets his
first big league home run tonight
and he wastes no time in getting his
second
and it's a six-four ball game how about
eli getting into this action again and
it brings up correa who's been hit by a
pitch scored a run he's also struck out
and grounded out
ground ball fair ball down the third
base line that'll bounce off the wall
jordan alvarez scores he's like carlos
in the second rbi double
astros regain that three-run cushion
it's 7-4
astros with a 7-4 lead jose altuve got
the astros started on the right foot
with his sixth leadoff home run of the
season
and altuve sends one high and deep to
left field jose altuve
onto the train tracks
train number 27.
has just left union station
all he does is hit homers
who has that high velocity fastball to
go along along with that splitter this
one on the ground altuve will go to
correa for one carlos turns the double
play game over
two-game sweep for the astros
six home runs tonight a season high
altuve with two of them
and the astros win eight to four
eleven games over for the first time
this year and blummer the astros
continue to play very good baseball